monsieur michel aflak vous êtes le père
spirituel en même temps que le
théoricien du parti baas c'est à dire du
parti socialiste de la résurrection
arabe
or le barça a largement contribué le 8
février à bagdad à la chute du régime
kacem et depuis le 8 mars damas
ce sont les hommes du bas ce que l'on
retrouve au levier de commande comment
se fait-il donc que vous ne figurez pas
dans l'équipe ministérielle cyrielle
savez bien que le parti baas existe dans
plusieurs pays arabes
je suis le secrétaire général du comité
national de ce parti et je n'en ai pas
je n'appartiens pas à un seul prix c'est
pour cela
je préfère rester loin du pouvoir et
nous concentrer sur le travail du parti
à l'intérieur pourrait vous monsieur
aflac mais précisé les objectifs du bas
sur le plan des relations interarabes
nous considérons que parmi les cinq pays
arabes libérés qui sont l'irak la syrie
l'egypte l'algérie le yémen doit
se former une pintade ou plutôt un front
progressiste et du berry mais trois de
ces cinq pays présente des conditions
propices pour une union politique
vous pensez bien entendu à l'irak à la
syrie et à la république a béni oui
cette union qui est exigé par les masses
populaires
[Musique]
seul thomas e
va profiter de la première expérience il
ya cinq 5 ans pour asseoir des bases
plus solides et plus réaliste pour celle
des négociations sont engagées au caire
entre égyptiens syriens et irakiens
pensez vous que ces négociations
puissent aboutir positivement
je suis très optimiste
j'ai la certitude qu'ils tuent et
puisqu'il faut envisager le pire
en cas d'échec de ces négociations du
caire pensez vous qu'il existe une
formule de rechange pour l'irak et la
syrie
par exemple est ce que ces deux pays
pourraient envisager une forme d'union
sous l'égide du baas nous ne voulons pas
de la politique des as
puisque les conditions nécessaires et
révolutionnaire pour l'union sans dans
ces centres
ce taux n'est ce pas dans ces trois pays
il faut que l'union se passe entre ces
trois pays et ainsi nous déjouerons les
manoeuvres impérialiste et
sioniste et réactionnaire qui essayent
de semer la division
[Musique]